[Music]
architecture has the power to
inspire behavior that's friendlier
more generous more loving and more
caring
simply by the way it's designed
fostering
a community building and a sense of
identity
so we spend a lot of time actually
trying to really get to know
our clients and really go into how they
live
together in 2001 we took part in the
international competition for the
pinnacle and duxton
that called for an innovative high-rise
high-density public housing design we
were inspired by the fact that every
person and every being in our entire
planet is interconnected
and interdependent seeing this made us
strive to create an order that would
model
our planet's design these would be open
spaces of hospitality that respect
culture and history across generations
these spaces would host people
flora and fauna with coherence and
simplicity
offering a freedom of being in the
course of our research on density
we had a revelation that singapore is an
extremely
relevant model of a compact city
we only need 1 000 singapores or roughly
the size of france
to house the entire world imagine that
if
one singapore can be safe within
planetary boundaries
and be a space of justice for all then
one thousand singapores can be a safe
and just
model for the entire world we feel
that the architect as an authentic
listener and seer
is something we should nurture by
adopting
a mindset of curiosity and taking the
time to understand the world
and the people we are designing for we
will be better able
to integrate the complexities of life
i love to journey with my students and
help them to connect with their deepest
creative selves
and their unique gifts to anchor this
sense of responsibility for the common
[Music]
good
you